I was home-schooled for three years and
I didn't get any of those skills panas
directed by Joe Wright stars sheersha
Roman I looked that up Eric Bana and
Cate Blanchet the film starts with a
father and a daughter played by bana and
Ronan who live in a forest and she's
never known anything except the secluded
forest life and he's training her to be
able to survive with fighting skills
teaching her different languages all
different types of things basically you
learn from the beginning that they are
on the run from some people she has to
defend herself that they're going to
have to be separated and she's gonna be
alone he needs to teach her everything
that he can eventually that does happen
they separate and becomes a big chase
film where Cate Blanchet is after Ronan
and Eric man is out in another area and
they're after him as well so he has all
this stuff he has to take care of a
friend I saw this whiff described it in
the best way ever he said that it's an
artsy Bourne film and that's exactly
what it is that's a great way to
describe it it's incredibly different
for this type of film you'd expect it to
be a lot more thriller esque just a
straightforward you know chase film but
it's not like that this is kind of like
an arthouse action film believe it or
not in some ways it worked very well and
others it didn't I was talking with my
friend and we agreed 100% in this film
which is pretty awesome he said this and
I agree with him it seemed like there
were two different movies in this film
there was like this art type film and
there was this action film and both of
them were done well both of them had
things about them that were appealing
but putting them together it seemed out
of place a little bit but at the same
time the film was always appealing and
watchable the character of the girl was
very interesting and there was a lot of
humor in the fact that she's never
experienced things like electricity or
the television there's this great scene
where she thinks she has to hunt food
even though there's
restaurants and stuff everywhere so your
shot is excellent in this film she's
only sixteen years old and she's an
actress well beyond her years she's very
good she was very good the lovely bones
also erik van is good as well and kate
Lynch that is excellent she is so good
at changing her accent and I gotta say I
thought she was really pretty in this
movie too sure my name is Kelly from the
x-files the film has very well done
action sequences good choreography well
done with the filming to because it
wasn't all shaky or close-up it was nice
and wide my favorite scene in this
entire film I couldn't quite tell if it
really was but they made it to look like
it was all done in one shot I'm pretty
sure they had some cuts in there when
they would film past a wall or something
they could probably get a little cut in
there but it was all done to look like
in one shot it was a very good action
scene I really like that the film looks
really pretty it's just that my main
problem is like it's two different films
in one almost it just it didn't always
fit for me it seemed a little disjointed
but I still enjoyed this film when I'm
gonna give it three out of four stars
great acting good action but just a
little bit separated you know it didn't
seem completely cohesive